welcome to big think live I'm Megan
Erickson and our guest today is Jesse
Bering a scholar in residence at wells
College a columnist at Scientific
American comm and the author of why is
the penis shaped like that and other
reflections on being human Jesse welcome
to the program hi Megan thanks all right
so we'll start with our first question
which is kind of an obvious one why is
the penis shaped I thought you'd never
ask
no it's that's the titular title of this
collection and if you think about the
shape of the penis it's not immediately
apparent why it's shaped the way that it
is it looks very different from penises
of other primate species and I talked
about in the book how I've unfortunately
seen more gorilla penises and chimpanzee
penises and orangutan penises and I care
to mention because I used to do research
with them but ours are large basically
compared especially large compared to
other species even closely related
species like these and it's also very
distinctive in its shape I'm gonna have
to use my hands here I don't know way to
get around this here but there's the
sort of mushroom caps or glands it's
called her the head of the penis with
the long serve rigid shaft I'm talking
about a tumescent penis of course and
the coronal Ridge which is the sort of
umbrella lip-lip underneath the
underneath the glans head and that
really seems to be the key from an
evolutionary perspective the fact that
we've got this really pronounced coronal
Ridge that in the front is actually this
little again I'm using my hand so I
don't like doing this but there's a
there's a friend you'll on the sort of
thin tab of skin basically so all these
unique features of the human penis
compared to the you know basically sort
of insemination device of chimpanzees is
revealing about what it's for so the
argument is basically that the the
coronal Ridge serves to retract
semen from the vaginal tract that had
been deposited there from another male
that had sex with the same woman and
pulls it out basically it's a sperm
competition type of
Amick so the more you're having vigorous
intercourse and thrusting pelvic ly into
the vaginal canal the more you're
pulling out whatever semen is there and
it's collecting in this sort of friend
ulam area and it's gathering down toward
the base of the phallus and you
ejaculate and you immediately go flaccid
typically you know I'm not immediately
but there's a
anybody who says who has a penis or has
interacted with a penis before no is
that once you have an orgasm you know
you don't want to continue usually don't
want to continue thrusting or it's not
doesn't really feel good and and that's
that's good because it's not
self-defeating or not pulling out your
own semen that you're depositing and the
other thing you know sighs like I said
it's big compared to other species I
mean gorillas are you know they're like
you know they're hung like gnats they're
450 pound 50 pounds but they're not
terribly impressive in that particular
area
and but ours are large and I've seen
some human penises too I must say and
the the size matters because it matters
actually more for the man because the
deeper you go the largely are the deeper
you're going to go and the more
difficult is going to be for whatever
males follow you at least if you're a
heterosexual male to pull out whatever
sperm cells that you deposit so size
does matter and it matters actually
although it might have sensational
you know effects for the woman in terms
of feeling good it actually matters more
from the reproductive interests of the
male the book the bigger you are the
better alright thanks and so you're
welcoming and so you mentioned the sort
of titular attraction of that title and
you people are fascinated by these
questions just intrinsically but there's
also I imagine a larger scientific value
and social value for learning about
evolutionary
psychology and biology and so what I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about that right since some of this sort
of applied benefits of learning about
these types yes why why if you're not a
scientist should write and be
interesting well I mean first of all I
think it's I think this work is it's not
my work so I can say this without
feeling like I'm boasting it's really
fascinating research that these
scientists have done from an
evolutionary perspective and you know
just understanding anatomical parts that
you know for all human history have gone
you know they've been there but we
haven't asked what are they for
you know why what's the function of
something that we're so intimately
familiar with we forget to ask ourselves
these things it's right our face maybe
not right in our face but sometimes it's
in our face and we skip the we skip
those types of questions because it's so
close to the surface it's only when we
sort of get a scientific perspective and
step back and ask these sort of
objective questions about something as
common as the penis or a female orgasm
or female ejaculation or yeah these sort
of salacious things that people probably
wonder about you know they're curious
about but they don't necessarily pursue
the scientific literature to understand
them in any meaningful way so you know I
think and that's actually a good example
that the the female ejaculation point
which is something that sounds
outrageous but in fact you know for a
long time
sexologist thought it was a myth they
didn't think that women could actually
ejaculate and I'm not talking about just
sort of vaginal lubrication I'm talking
about expelling copious amounts of fluid
very much like a male seminal emission
but many women do report having these
sort of ejaculatory experiences and they
thought they were urinating a bit
because they thought that they were
somehow of income you know incontinent
and the the husbands and the boyfriends
would get upset and why can't you go to
bathroom before you have sex and they
just didn't understand that this was
actually not urine this was actually a
type of sexual fluid that women
experience when they're intensely
aroused and it saves marriages I mean I
think just having those facts and
understanding that this is not anomalous
this is normal this is not something to
be ashamed of
and looking at it from a very sort of
clinical objective perspective that is
reduces anxiety to leave the AIT's our
sense of shame and it has practical
consequences for how we interact with
each other yeah and there's something
you said there that I really wanted to
follow up on which is the sense of shame
that is often part of our conversation
about biology so I'm wondering if having
a better understanding of the way
biology shapes our motivations and our
actions if you think that that will
impact the way we talk about sex as a
culture do you see that happening now do
you think what do you think about the
future I do think so I'm actually this
is one of the few areas where I'm
actually optimistic I'm generally more
of a pessimist but I think that the more
we learn and discuss very openly and
frankly things that are that have
historically developmentally been
shameful for us and just get it out
there and talk about it even though it
might have that sort of intrinsic
snicker factor I mean it's fine for
people to laugh cuz these are kind of
funny Thanks and but they're also they
strike at the heart of being human and
so much goes unsaid in the domain of
sexuality in particular that we don't
realize how much we have in common with
other people the same types of issues
that people have today they were having
yeah they were experiencing 200 years
ago I spent last summer at a couple of
weeks at the Kinsey Institute at Indiana
University in Bloomington and was going
through all the historical archives and
the Autobots a sexual autobiographies of
people that would write to Alfred Kinsey
about you know all their weird sexual
fetishes and paraphilias and childhood
experiences with sex and I mean it's
it's like I mean it's basically these
their experiences memmer their mirror
exactly what we're still going through
today so not a lot has changed really I
mean even though we've taken a more
scientific perspective I still think we
have a ways to go but you know you
wouldn't think that your great
grandmother for example you know
ever thought about female ejaculation
but you know she probably might have had
it herself and it's just not something
that we think about in terms of other
people but I think it's it has a
humanitarian value just being
sympathetic and understanding about
people's sex lives mm-hmm um and so when
it comes to the humanitarian value do
you see evolutionary psychology and
biology as kind of reductionist or
mechanistic at all
yeah it's both reductionistic
increasingly reductionistic the deeper
and more intricate you go in terms of
the mechanisms and explaining particular
traits or behavioral patterns or
psychological processes and it's
deterministic all of science is really
deterministic I do think it has and I do
think this is part of the reason that
people are oftentimes very uncomfortable
with evolutionary interpretations of
human behavior because they feel like if
it's evolved then we have no escape from
you know a particular route going one
way one way or the other but most you
know evolutionary psychologists worth
their salt are not explicitly or
exclusively deterministic in the sense
that you know something is adaptive it's
evolved therefore we have no control
over what we do with that particular
trait obviously every all of human
behavior is incredibly complex and to
influence fire learning experiences and
hereditary and culture and but the the
evolutionary argument is it's
particularly potent I think because
first of all it reminds people that were
animals and just like any other animal
we have you know people don't like
Easy's you don't like to use word
instinct and I think it's a very loaded
word but we do have evolved algorithms
that strongly favor particular responses
in the face of particular stimuli and it
has implications I think for people's
conceptions of free will because the
more deterministic and reductionistic it
becomes the more people feel like they
have no control over their
behavior and personally I don't think
that there is such a thing it's free
well I think it's an illusion I think
it's a psychological illusion that we
can reflect upon our own mental contents
and you know try to take the perspective
of what we would do why we were thinking
what we're thinking when we made a
decision at the time but in fact it's
all just retrospective and I think it's
largely a cognitive illusion and simply
knowing this about our ourselves has
effects we know from psychology
experiments if you tell people that
there is no free will and you you couch
behavioral explanations in terms of
determinism causal determinism it
actually genuinely makes them more
selfish makes them less altruistic and
it's a it's not effect really I mean
social psychology has demonstrated this
that the more people think you don't
have free will the worse you behave or
the worse they behave and I don't know
there's any real you know simple way to
get around that problem I think just
simply understanding how that works and
taking stock of why we feel that way can
have effects also on our you know our
emotional responses to say the freewill
question yeah and you wrote in the book
I remember one scene where you were
particularly talking about a scientific
paper that you had read and scientists
mentioned sort of covering up from
people from society the idea that we
don't have fun well yeah yeah so where
does that leave us what are the larger
implications that that that's a big one
I mean I was asked to write a piece in
response to that article originally when
it was published in Scientific American
about you know what would I recommend
basically if some if a scientist
stumbled upon something that that once
people knew about it in terms of their
understanding of human nature it would
dramatically affect how they behave
socially to in a in a very deleterious
way a very sort of malignant way dude
does the scientist is the scientist
ethically obligated to shield those
facts of that information
the receptive public or from you know at
least somehow frame the answers in a way
that is more palatable to the readers or
to the public and I don't know I mean I
think the I think we all the ideal sort
of sight scientific approach would be
suck truth is truth and we've got to get
it out despite you know everything no
matter what the consequences and I do
feel strongly that of course we should
do that but I also think it's sort of
it's it's an it's an interesting sort of
plaything of a thought that you know
perhaps there are some things that are
better left unsaid because of the
effects that they could actually have an
in society I don't believe that I just I
just simply think it's an interesting
problem right okay well thank you so
much for being with us today Jesse those
are all really interesting points that
you raised and we invite our big think
audience to check out Jesse's new book
why is the penis shaped like that and
other reflections on being human and to
check back two big thing calm to watch
additional video clips from our
conversation with Jesse and to find out
about future live interviews with our
experts thanks for watching
[Music]
you